Oh, to add to the glucose question a month ago or so, I'd go to my colleges for my injections
and before getting them, they'd take my blood around 2 p.m. by glucose, who'd come out
at about 82 hours after eating lunch.
Okay, so little known fact is that your glucose, if you took your glucose right after you ate
lunch, even if it wasn't a high carb lunch, your glucose will spike.
It's normal, that's a post-gradual glucose test, and it's normal to spike up, but then it
drops down, and then it balances out.
So that's why you wanted, if you're going to be taking your glucose levels to measure
your glucose levels, you want to take it at a 10 or 12 hour fast on a regular basis, don't
do this because it'll give you a false rating of, oh, it's down to 80, that's almost in
the 70s, that's really good, yeah, because it's just dropped, it plummeted from a high
after eating, and now it'll go up 80, 90, 95, and then that will be your normal.
So it's not a fair assessment of really where your glucose levels are on average.